Once upon a time, there was a boy who was
born into a family of simple tailors in the
middle of sub-Saharan Africa. The boy’s father
wanted him to continue the family business,
but the boy wanted a better life and one night
decided to leave his home and go to Europe.
To cross the sea the boy built himself
a raft. But once he left the shore,
there was only a little wind and it didn’t
take long for his supplies to run out. And
there he was: hungry, and lonely, floating
in the middle of the mediterranean sea.
Imagine you live on the coast of
Southern Europe and one morning,
read about the boy's fate in a local
paper. Should you yourself try to save him?
Four influential philosophers — Aristotle, Mill,
Kant, and Nietzsche — can help us answer this,
and other difficult moral questions
with their respective theories.